gestern war es wieder mal soweit tag der
deutschen einheit oder wie wir hier seit
jahren liebevoll nennen unseren händen
state meine damen und herren ja ja
gestern haben sich alle deutschen auf
das wirklich wesentliche besonnen das
heute brückentag ist spaß dieses jahr
ist es natürlich sie ahnen es besonders
emotional wegen 30 jahre mauerfall ist
ja klar
ich prophezeie den ganzen herbst kommen
jetzt immer wieder diese tollen bilder
hoch von der magischen nacht damals aldi
glückstrunken menschen die ganzen
hoffnungen immer wieder schön morgen
anders werden ja nicht wo sie ist auch
quatsch oder mal ehrlich jede menge hat
sich geändert als der tatsache zuständig
für den festakt 2009 10 war gestern die
stadt kiel schleswig holstein
falls sie es im fernsehen verpasst haben
weil sie ein leben haben
ich sag mal so auf der bühne gab es im
prinzip ja das übliche irgendeine poetry
slammerin die 89 noch nicht mal quark
ins schaufenster war durfte was vorlesen
dann wurde dem publikum der aufregende
beruf der sandmalerin vorgestellt und
volksschauspieler axel prahl bekam das
gericht zur deutschen einheit serviert
den sogenannten mail beutel
dazu gibt es denn der stoß butter soßen
zu schweinen und zirkulation senden
kirsch sauce mit senf endlich wächst
zusammen was nicht zusammengehört meine
damen und herren gut tatsächlich gibt es
natürlich auch erfolgsmeldungen im
jubiläumsjahr das ist fakt ja gehört
auch dazu
die wirtschaftskraft der neuen länder
liegt aktuell bei 75 prozent des
westniveaus 1990 waren es gerade mal 43
prozent das ist also ein ganz klarer
erfolg was nervt am tag der deutschen
einheit muss ich zugeben ist dieses jahr
dieses hole dieses ritual hafte auch bei
uns in den medien ja klar
seit jahrzehnten quält man uns gefühlt
mit den immer gleichen bildern in den
immer gleichen einheits dokus mit den
immer gleichen leute nachts immer darauf
jedes mal die szene wo dieser eine
alkoholiker denkt er singt die mauer
kaputt dann erzählen irgendwelche
schnarchen zeit zeugen wo sie in der
nacht des mauerfalls waren
ich war wie schon oft dargestellt habe
mit einer freundin in der sauna gewesen
ja weil du dich nicht für politik
interessiert und dann kommt immer wieder
uhr alle clips wo wessis oder ossis
lästern
die sind in der bekleidung nicht so
still sicher kann uns westberliner wird
gesagt dass sie nur meckern aber die
männer nehmen noch mehr wie viele
ostdeutsche kennen sie
dr
die reichen ja süß
[Applaus]
die sims zusammengewachsen auch im jahr
2019 fühlen sich 57 prozent der
ostdeutschen als bürger zweiter klasse
zu erschrecken und natürlich drückt das
auf die partystimmung ist ja klar ist ja
klar
nach einer nach einer aktuellen studie
sind gerade mal 1,7 prozent der
spitzenposition in wirtschaft und
verwaltung von ostdeutschen besetzt nur
1,7 das ist unfassbar
bei vielen bewerbungsgesprächen läuft
das wahrscheinlich so ab du erzählst
denen gut gelaunt wie qualifiziert du
bist ne ich spreche englisch französisch
spanisch mandarin
alles läuft super und dann sieht der
personalchef plötzlich diesen einen
punkt in deinem lebenslauf
ich würde sagen
[Applaus]
beim anteil an der bevölkerung ist nicht
schön und bei uns in der
unterhaltungsindustrie oder beim
fernsehen siehst du auch nicht besser
aus was die rollenverteilung angeht das
muss man ja eiskalt ganz klar zu geben
natürlich kein einziger uni-rektor ist
ostdeutscher kein einziger bundesrichter
ist ostdeutscher die einzige ostdeutsche
doku ministerin ist vdv und die wohl
nicht mehr lange
kurz gesagt es ist also noch viel zu tun
vor allem müssen mehr firmen in die
neuen länder gelockt werden mit
steuervergünstigungen
sonderwirtschaftszonen keine ahnung oder
ganz andere idee wir machen was was nix
kostet wir brauchen einen neuen einen
ganz anderen solidarpakt einen der
offenen ohren und des offenen austauschs
ein solidarpakt der wertschätzung
ja
du weißt du musst ein ganz besonderer
ossi sein wenn oper frankfurt er seine
wertschätzung schenken jedes jahr um
diese zeit faseln alle von der
angleichung der lebensverhältnisse in
einem land das sonst mit ungleichheit
überhaupt kein problem hat ganz neue
zahlen der nach einkommen unteren hälfte
in deutschland gehören gerade mal 1,3
prozent des vermögens angleichung
vorschlag man gibt den neuen neuen
ländern wenigstens mehr bundesbehörden
und mehr bundeseinrichtungen den
zuschlag für ein neues
batterieforschungszentrum hielt gerade
erst die stadt münster in sachsen-anhalt
münster in nordrhein westfalen herzlich
willkommen zur psp2 kommt wohl nicht
wahr sein der uns gut ist und bleibt
aber auch blockierten cloud von waagen
an meine damen und herren leitet die
bundesbehörde für die gerechte
verteilung von bundesbehörden hermann
wagner
warum münster ein standort in der
lausitz hatte sich doch auch beworben
und was mir gerade einfällt kommt unsere
forschungs ministerin frau carlitscheck
nicht zufällig aus dem münsterland jetzt
geht es wieder los
anja karliczek ist aus der gegend da
sich das reiche münster auch noch
batterien hinten reingeschoben das war
auch keine entscheidung gegen die
aussies also natürlich war das nur
entscheidung gegen die aussies aber die
ministerin drückt das eben viel schöner
aus wir brauchen eher autos und dafür
müssen wir jetzt ganz schnell
einsatzfähig werden in der produktion
neuartig gestalteter batterien und das
hätten sie der lausitz nicht zugetraut
es geht ja nicht darum wen wir etwas zu
trauern sondern wir müssen immer gucken
wo ist das know how vorhanden
und da hat man eben gemerkt im osten
halt nicht
also jedenfalls nicht für so etwas
komplexes wie batterieforschung
verstehen sie mich nicht falsch
natürlich können die auch sachen ja
räuchermännchen aus dem erzgebirge
das ist wunderbar als oben ein loch
trainer kommt dann sobald ja ich weiß
das haben die aus sich selber erfunden
das wissen viele gar so neuhaus durchaus
da manche das land sachsen hatte fürs
batterie zentrum schon diese halle
gekauft in großröhrsdorf und paar meter
entfernt in dresden sitzt das
frauenhofer institut die haben glaube
ich in know how auch für batterien ja
mein tipp liebe sachsen so eine halle
erst kaufen wenn man den zuschlag hat
können sie jetzt spreewaldgurken drin
lara gut seht ihr die aussies vor allem
den 193 meinem kaputten vw jetta gekauft
hat herr welke batterieforschung das ist
hightech das ist international
da musst du regelrecht englisch können
sowie die an ihr
einen losen okay beim bauen
[Applaus]
die schalotte fein dreher ich auch nicht
ich glaube das alles nicht 1992 hat der
deutsche bundestag beschlossenen neue
bundes behörden bevorzugt in den osten
zu vergeben
seitdem haben sie 20 neue einrichtungen
im westen angesiedelt aber nur fünf im
osten hier so sieht das heute aus echt
fair verteilt oder und das sind nur die
behörden berlin aber rausgelassen sie
sind neutral von 219 bundeseinrichtungen
haben 194 ihren sitz im westen 25 im
osten also entschuldigung es geht ja
hier nicht um quantität sie müssen mal
gucken welche tollen einrichtung der
austria zum beispiel das
bundesforschungsinstitut für
kulturpflanzen in quedlinburg so dass
hätten münster auch gab ja ja ist aber
nachdrücklich kann ja was wollen sie da
drüben noch ein starkes signal war ganz
am anfang der dies der unserer jetzigen
bundesregierung die ansiedlung des
bundesfernstraßen amtes in leipzig oder
etwa auch die vergabe des
kompetenzzentrums kompetenzzentrums wald
nach mecklenburg vorpommern
die haben das komplette kompetenzzentrum
wald
seit januar ist der osten für den wald
zuständig und jetzt frage ich sie welche
wie sieht der deutsche wald heute aus
keine weiteren fragen claus von wagner
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag überall lassen
ihre risiken liegen und ihr lasst jetzt
slx ein beschissenes abo da
[Musik]